man I just want to open my Christmas
presents well I'm waiting on you to
finish those snake costumes I'm almost
done
you know what they're good enough I'm
done all right let's go
all right we're landing come on man I
can't believe we're almost done Rick I
can practically taste the eggnog hey you
know what I feel like we're forgetting
something oh yeah thanks for reminding
me Morty
next time stay in the car you know I
can't believe we're back we're gonna be
back I mean it's right we're gonna be
back
the space snake episode has been around
for seasons it was an idea we couldn't
quite crack in season 3 we always knew
how the episode was gonna start we loved
the idea of like getting a flat tire in
space it's always fun to do terrestrial
things in a dumb sci-fi way and we're
laughing and how dumb it would be to see
a little snake and like a little
astronaut suit made for snakes you know
like what is it doing out there you know
it's like the dumbest thing ever they're
gross little holdovers from from when we
evolved from worms my appearance is
designed to be familiar and put you at
ease we didn't know was gonna be like a
sort of time-traveling like Terminator
II thing that was the thing that turned
it into a full episode for this season
like we never had that before
if we're gonna make a whole snake
society and go down this dumb loophole
and and do all this dumb stuff that the
biggest dumb leap we could do is
time-travel snakes snakes they suck
they're not supposed to have space
programs do there that's was to live and
dominate a planet however if they do
there is one artifact of it that makes
it all worth it snake jam a Merry
Christmas welcome back everyone it's
Charlie I know everybody's got big
questions about what's going on with the
next episodes of Rick and Morty when is
season 4 coming back like they say 2020
sometime they've been a couple
interviews with the cast and crew
recently they give us a much better
window for when the episodes will
actually be done and I'm talking about
episodes 6 through 10 so we'll break it
down if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the
easter-egg videos I will be doing Rick
and Morty videos while we wait for the
rest of the season four episodes to get
here so no worries and I will keep doing
that Rick and Morty merch giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best evil
Morty theory on the video I'll name a
new winner at the end of this so
addressing that season 4 episode 5 post
credits scene that's mostly them just
trying to explain the infinite time loop
that present Rick and present Morty wind
up creating for themselves to help
themselves in the past with the snake
time travel problem
version of Rick and Morty whose
perspective we've been following through
the episode the whole time like even
when future Rick and future Morty come
back to help them you stay with the
present version of Rick and Morty those
two have now got to the point in their
own future through the course of the
episode when it's time to make the snake
costumes and snake math lessons to give
to themselves in the past a lot of you
had questions about the paradox that the
writers created in this moment here
because they don't explain everything
but they give you some clues when they
walk into the house at the end of the
episode their future selves come back to
make fun of them because now it's their
turn to do all the heavy labor haha we
get to go have eggnog and do Christmas
stuff while you guys had to do all the
dirty work the present version of
Morty's like why are you being so mean
why do you have to be a dick about it
and the future version of Morty says
well you know we don't but the other
versions before that did this to us just
a little while ago they were mean to us
so now we're gonna be mean to you
implying that this isn't the first time
loop so this is where everyone started
to get confused like wait a minute how
many time loops has this been through
which version are we on right now thus
the paradox that the writers created
because you don't know where you are in
this loop are we on the first loop are
we on the tenth loop the 15th how many
it's a phenomenon like those episodes of
Rick and Morty where you're not sure if
you're following the actual real version
of c-137 Rick and his version of Morty
like wait a minute which version of Rick
and Morty are we following around this
entire time so we'll call the versions
that we've been following the entire
episode Rick prime and Morty prime the
original versions for all intents and
purposes even though that's technically
not confirmed so in the post-credits
scene where prime Rick punches Morty
prime in the face to sort of complete
their time loop because he kind of
reminded himself early in the episode
I'm reminding myself to commit to your
stupidity even more they then walk into
the building and hand these items to
their younger selves to help them out
then they go back home collect the books
and the snake carcasses and hand them to
their past selves again then it becomes
their turn to be dicks to their younger
selves as they go then and have eggnog
and do fun Christmas stuff while their
other past selves have to do all the
heavy lifting now so let me know in the
comments the first time we see this
scene how many loops do you think that
they've been through when they get to
this moment is a perfect example of the
paradox because you're like wait a
minute when did the loop start who's the
first version that did the
in the very reason why a long time ago
Dan Harmon said he never really intended
on messing with time travel on Rick and
Morty that was the whole reason for them
putting that box of time-travel stuff in
the garage in the pilot episode just as
a funny way of saying we're gonna put
this on a shelf and never go there we're
gonna pack it up and put it away because
a lot of times it winds up not totally
making sense and unless you can find a
funny way of pulling it off it can
totally hurt the story in the case of
this episode though I think the out that
they gave themselves is when future Rick
and future Morty's start making fun of
present Rick and present Morty here they
start talking about how much doing all
this work sucks they don't want to do it
is the writers winking behind the camera
saying figuring out how to do time
travel in episodes then figuring out
scenes like this is a ton of work and
kind of sucks and they don't really want
to do it but as they say during the
inside the episode promo they committed
to the Terminator parody and that meant
that they had to do time travel and
since they had to do it why not do it in
the most ridiculous way possible which
is why throughout the episode Rick is
constantly calling out time-travel
tropes in breaking the fourth wall
saying that this time travel story sucks
and he wants out of the episode but
addressing the rest of the season four
episodes when they're gonna release
season 4 episodes 6 through 10 there was
a recent interview with Spencer Grammer
who plays summer on the show a few weeks
ago where she said she had just recorded
her voiceover dialogue for the season 4
finale that season 4 episode 10 because
they confirmed a long time ago that
season 4 has 10 full episodes they just
broke it into two halves because it
sounds like they're so behind on
animation and if you're not familiar
with how long it actually takes to make
a Rick and Morty episode it can take
them up to a year between the time they
record the actors voice over dialogue
for an episode and when the animation
and touch-ups are done and the episode
can actually be aired so if she just
recorded season 4 episode 10 back in
October that means that they might not
be ready to start releasing season 4
episodes 6 through 10 until next summer
at the latest but I think that's a
worst-case scenario but that gives us a
little better window for when they're
actually going to release episodes
before I saw this interview I'd assume
that they were just gonna take the break
during the holidays and then come back
in January but they haven't said
anything about it since then if you
wonder why it takes so long to
mate episodes of Rick and Morty why
takes a full year to finish all that
stuff there's a podcast Adult Swim has
been doing with the episodes this year
as a companion to the episodes with the
animators the people behind the scenes
one of the animators explained that the
actual animation of Rick and Morty is so
complex compared to shows like Family
Guy or even The Simpsons or South Park
that it takes way longer to animate the
episodes than those other typical
animated Network shows but as far as
what the actual stories of the rest of
the five episodes during season four
going to be there's the interdimensional
cable 3 episode which Justin teased a
while ago he was actually in a recording
booth when he was teasing this there's a
special Beth episode that they talked
about back at comic-con and then there's
still the big season 5 evil Morty and
credits scene tag that they talked about
back at Comic Con as well so because we
didn't really see that during episode 5
I'm assuming that they're talking about
season 4 episode 10 this is the clip of
that I've talked about this in a couple
episodes so far but they hype it up big
time I wanted to record it and think not
I'm like I can't but I don't get to
record it but like it's maybe my most
favorite speech it's so good it's so
good then the response it's just it's so
good finale of season 4 is really good
yeah so based on what Justin says it
sounds like there's some heavy
Canonical's story episodes coming up in
the back half of season 4 as opposed to
the more one-off adventure stories that
we saw in the first half what'll happen
is I'll do more Rick and Morty bonus
videos in the next couple of weeks
through the holidays leave all your
requests in the comments below
congratulations Roscoe you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Rick &
Morty video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details I'm allowed to post my
non-spoilery Star Wars rise of Skywalker
review at midnight tonight as I'm
posting this video so as long as you
have alerts enabled for that you should
see the video when I post it but it'll
be really really late tonight
everyone click here for my full Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 5 video and click
here for my brand new Mandalorian
episode 6 video thank you so much for
watching happy holidays everyone I'll
see you guys tonight
you